le théâtre très tard les enfants très
tard m'a attendu trois semaines c'est
vous dire je suis arrivé encore en
retard de trois semaines c'est drôle
on pourrait boire un verre Françoise
tu veux nous apporter quelque chose à
boire tu serais mignon ma puce qu'est-ce
que vous voulez pierre il y a des jus de
fruits lui de l'eau dit-il
de l'eau minérale non il y a de l'eau de
source ici oui c'est pas vrai mais je le
dis toujours
c'est
forcément c'est pas uniquement les
enfants c'est aussi un homme dans sa vie
normalement sans absolument normal je ne
suis pas le genre de femme en plus de 6
si j'ai une passion pour mon petit c'est
vraiment ce qui est le plus important
pour moi mais je peux très bien vivre
sans lui enfin il arriverait quoi que ce
soit je ne pourrai plus vivre je veux
dire par là mais je ne je n'ai pas tout
branché sur lui du moment qu'il est en
bonne santé du moment que il n'a pas de
problème que je le sens heureux j'ai
toute une autre vie normale s'il y a
quelque chose bien sûr je ne pense plus
qu'à ça alors donc je pense que pour
être une femme parfaitement t'es pas oui
il faut que ce soit complet voyez-vous
monsieur oui oui je vois ça d'ici
pourquoi vous l'avez fait si tard on
m'avait dit que vous faites pareil
le théâtre très tard les enfants très
tard caché au niveau monde aussi maman
m'a attendu trois semaines c'est vous
dire je suis arrivé encore en retard de
trois semaines c'est drôle d'avoir un
fils de très très jeune fils de 10 ans
bah c'est-à-dire que je regrette un
petit peu oui j'aime bien ce que
j'aurais aimé voyez-vous si en avoir un
qui est 20 ans oui parce que j'aurais
bien aimé une fille aussi une de 20 ans
et puis celui-là maintenant ça c'est
alors là ça aurait été mais j'ai jamais
rien c'est simplement que je m'y
attendais plus et il est arrivé et
c'était merveilleux
et j'élève très bien très très bien
vous me dites que vous êtes optimiste et
vous m'avez ça tout à l'heure et puis
vous si vous avez
été agacé par le stress de du danger
qu'on entretient autour des gens le
stress de la mort oui
on dirait que vous forcez
à ne plus avoir tout ça
oui
bah oui puis c'était
une chose qui m'a hantée très parent
dans une certaine période de ma vie qui
était très oui et ça a été tellement dur
et pénible que bon ben
quand on sait quand on l'a touché très
près quand on
combien ça peut et puis c'est un Pacôme
c'est le seul qui reste
il y en avait beaucoup ils ont tous
alors il reste un pas comme pour ça que
je me suis pas marié vous y pensez
encore cette période on va dire
il y a des trucs qui ne se cicatrisent
jamais
qu'est-ce qu'on disait tout ça
avait été cette période ce que vous
voulez qu'il sache
j'ai eu l'impression tout au long de ça
fait plus d'une heure qu'on parle de
d'un optimisme à toute épreuve et
peut-être un tout petit peu
une connerie un peu forcé oui
comme c'est de gosses qui sifflent dans
la forêt vous savez il y a un petit peu
de ça et certains qui a un petit peu de
ça mais il y a des moments c'est pas
toujours pas toujours il y a des moments
où je suis resté très puérile par
exemple dans ma crédulité je suis très
très nul on me raconte une histoire je
suis je suis la dame rêvée pour le
premier avril on me fait croire des
choses
plus que fallait déléguer des oeufs
n'importe quoi dans les journaux de
toute façon ils savent très bien que
nous les femmes on est tellement dingue
qu'on va le faire quand même alors les
œufs je connaissais le truc de du masque
à l'oeuvre bon ça tout le monde connaît
mais où c'était corsé ce qu'il fallait
hacher du persil dedans et bien ma chère
je l'ai fait j'ai acheté du persil
et après c'était comment
la chirurgie esthétique c'est pour ça ah
moi j'y pense moi je suis pour je suis
absolument pour je suis pour parce que
je me dis si là ça va bien mon Dieu si
je m'écroule un petit peu dans un petit
lifting c'est pas ça fait une mal à
personne on voit on montre un visage un
peu plus frais et puis c'est beaucoup
mieux aussi bien pour moi je dis pas
pour les autres et tu es en train de
dire ou pour les autres pour ses enfants
mais non c'est pour moi quand je regarde
ma bouille dans la glace je veux pas
voir alors ça m'embêterait de mes cours
je crois pas que je m'écroulerais
voyez-vous j'aurais
pas ce serait pas une vieille pomme je
pense pas
c'est peut-être pour ça je me rassure
non mais ça compte aussi
mais bien sûr que ça compte par moment
quand je suis dedans en pleine forme
quand
[Musique]